so there are currently 23 people vying
for the Democratic presidential
nomination
that's more people running than ever
before it's a lot of people to keep
track of so today I'm in the park asking
voters how many candidates they can name
off of this poster board
[Music]
all right so who who can you man from
this whip oh my god
people like four people four people
[Music]
hickenlooper globish are not Rick Perry
but kind of looks like him
okay I know Bernie Sanders I feel like
I've seen a best knit bit about all
these but I only know a couple I know
her but I don't remember her name
de Blasio we got Bennett Biden Booker
Bullock Buddha judge Castro de Blasio
Delaney Gabbard Gillibrand Harris
Hickenlooper Inslee Klobuchar the guy
who's a mayor in Florida Moulton
O'Rourke Tim Ryan Sanders Sam swallow
well Warren Williams and yang
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one thing I'm noticing is that everyone
seems to be talking about the diversity
of the pool of candidates much more so
than the policies of candidates or their
familiarity with anyone running what do
you know about burning my family liked
him how do you feel about go to judge I
like him I like that a gay man a gay
veteran is in the conversation and being
taken seriously and I think that's
important I think he'd be like the first
mayor president I can't watch
Elizabeth Warren she screams all the
time that drives me crazy you know
something I don't mind Kamala Harris I
don't like her politics but I think she
has a smooth delivery never before
I'm actually like surprised to see so so
much diversity I would have hoped it was
smaller I would probably take almost any
other Republican to Trump personally
[Music]
typically would not vote Democrat so I
mean I'm in kind of a minority camp
where I probably won't get a candidate
you know at the other day well they all
are not gonna win so that is something
we can say for sure they're not all
gonna win so almost no one could name
all 23 candidates and there's still time
for even more people to enter the race
so it's a lot to keep track of and some
people are worried that this crowded
pool of candidates is going to overwhelm
voters only time will tell but if you
want to keep up with all of your 2020
news hit the subscribe button below
[Music]